a lot of fences security analyst
Professor Michael Clarke is here with me
um and Michael the first lady of Ukraine
taking to a big stage there so many
global leaders what's her overall aim in
speaking to them in Davos yes I mean
Elaine is a great Ambassador in that
respect because she represents
president's ideas and she's just right
for DeVos where they don't talk so much
about economics these days but wider
human issues so it's all pretty good the
Diplomatic community of of Kiev have
been out and about this week because
this is the moment when they want to
reinforce the backing of the western
world for the war in Ukraine and
particularly to get the equipment they
need for the offensives which we know
are going to begin on both sides round
about the end of the winter so whenever
that turns out to be beginning of April
end of March this is the last time when
the ukrainians can get hold of the stuff
they need from the West to really take
the war to the Russians so that's been
the message and I guess Elena's been
delivering isn't worthy the more human
side of that message compared to the
foreign minister and all of the other
yeah when we were talking yesterday we
talked about time being of the essence
in terms of Ukraine getting what it
needs we're halfway through winter we're
entering the next phase of this conflict
why is this next space so important do
you think it's important because of the
weather because when the weather eases
then we can expect this Battlefront
which has been relatively
um static for the last couple of months
it'll start to become much more fluid
because the Russians will turn up with a
lot of more a lot more troops maybe 200
000 more troops and rotate some of those
that are there with a lot of equipment
and the ukrainians also will bring more
of their Peak forces to the front line
again they hope with new equipment so I
think we'll see a lot of movement and
the point is that there's no there's no
point talking about the politics of this
or negotiations or a ceasefire until
these next battles have worked their way
through and a new outcome will be
created somewhere between let's say
March and April May June and only then
when we see a new situation on the
ground in June will we then be able to
talk about well where is the war going
what would the next phase be and so
sadly the only thing we can foresee in
Ukraine for the next two or three months
is more intense fighting and
Shuffle of his calendars leading this
war is that in preparation for the next
phase what what's his thinking yes it is
it's part of internal politics in the
Kremlin because he's got Warlords
Putin's got Warlords to to think about
pragos in and uh khadirov are leading
these forces the chechens case and the
Wagner group in prague's case and the
tale is beginning to Wag the Dog in
terms of their ability to create things
on the battlefield and so the military
Shogun the defense ministers tightened
up his chain of command they've demoted
sarovikian who was the commander and
karasimov the chief of all of the Armed
Forces now in charge of the whole
operation they've tightened that up so
that the Warlords don't actually end up
calling the shots and today only a few
hours ago shogu announced a series of
military reforms talking about creating
the equivalent of about 12 new divisions
new special forces to do various things
I'd just done a sort of quick tot up of
what he was talking about it looks to me
as if over 200 000 troops are being as
were created into new unit now they
won't all turn up on the Ukrainian
battlefield but a fair number of them
will and again this is shogo the defense
minister grabbing hold of the reins of
power in defense rather than let the
Warlords do it okay Michael thank you
Professor Michael Clark there with the
latest on Ukraine